a huge majority of One Piece was shot
with extremely wide angle lenses and
natural light with the camera often at
an awkwardly framed distance the speed
and authenticity of it all seldom landed
for me as a result and I think it's
interesting to look at yuu Haka shows in
comparison to find some obvious ways to
improve with camera lenses there's
something called focal length that
effectively defines the field of view
one piece is live action used wide angle
effectively nonstop the camera is
constantly distorting faces or framing
action with these huge sweeping angles
and I totally get the intent anime is
chucked full of this stuff and I imagine
the idea was to try to bring that to
life but I don't think the idea
translated as well as many might have
thought and it ended up looking quite
amateur at the worst of times if you
look at these phenomenally well-shot
YuYu Haka show sequences you can see all
of this perfectly cinematic framing that
knows when to go handheld when to use
Crane and orali and when to use a wide
angle for momentary effect